Another key component of understanding customers
is understanding customer gains, which is a fancy way for saying
what are the benefits that customers expect,
or desires, so besides the jobs they want to get done
what do they want to gain by using your product or service?
Let's take a look.
Some of the gains could be what would make them happy?
Is it saving money, saving effort, saving time,
and what do they expect, and what would go beyond their expectations?
How would you delight these customers?
Is it quality, more of something, less of something?
And is it features that would delight them or performance or quality?
And what would make your customer's job or life easier?
More services, lower cost of ownership, flatter learning curve?
Obviously this depends whether you're selling to business customers
or consumer customers, but you want to be able to make a list or a column
of all the gains that they would get by using your product.
And some more gains could be is it social consequences?
Does it make them look good, increase in power?
Is it good design? Is it specific or more features?
And how do they measure success and failure?
Is it performance or cost?
And what would increase their likelihood of adopting your product
or using it or using your solution?
Again, is it about cost?
Is it about lower risk? Is it about better quality?
Is it because it's more fun?
You need to come up with a series of hypotheses.
Just make that list now.
But you can't guess forever.
You have to validate these hypotheses.